NARRATOR: The
following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, ready for
the second lecture about --
second to last lecture about the
linear one-way wave equation,
so the model for
hyperbolic equations.
That word, hyperbolic,
tells me that signals are
traveling with finite speed.
In this case, the speed
is c and in this case,
the signals are only
going to the left.
The two-way wave equation
will travel left and right,
but again, finite speed.
I emphasize finite speed,
because for the heat equation,
the speed is infinite.
As soon as you change an initial
condition, at any later time,
you immediately feel the effect
-- probably a small effect way,
way out.
So diffusion travels
with infinite speed.
Waves travel with finite speed.
The difference sort of is that
the true true growth factor G
-- tiy remember, the
true growth factor was,
for the wave equation --
This is the G for the --
that multiplies the
exponential e to the i*k*x
in the difference equation
-- and G, the true G,
is e to the i*k*c*t.
So that -- what I
was going to say is,
that has absolute value 1.
Again, a difference
from the heat equation.
For the heat equation
with diffusion,
g will be smaller than 1.
You're losing energy.
For the wave equation,
the energy is constant
and the wave is just moving.
So it's a little more delicate,
because we're trying to --
this G in the difference
equation has to stay --
be somehow close to that one,
which is right on the unit
circle and yet,
we got to stay --
we can't go outside
the unit circle.
So here are two methods.
We had one method
last time that worked.
That was one-sided
differences and of course, you
had to take the difference on
the good side, the upwind side,
and that was first order.
The Courant-Friedrichs-Lewy
condition
was the same as the von
Neumann stability condition
and it was r between 0 and 1.
r is this ratio, c delta t
over delta x, it comes in.
It comes into the wave equation.
So now, we really have to
think about better methods,
other methods.
And here are two:
Lax-Friedrichs,
which will only be first order.
So when I -- these are the
questions I always ask,
and then finally, experiment.
I mean, answering these
questions will certainly
be a guide to what we'll
see experimentally,
but there's more to learn from
actually doing the numbers.
The accuracy, Lax-Fridrichs,
will be only first order,
whereas Lax-Wendroff
will be second order.
So with respect to accuracy,
that's certainly better.
Can we see that maybe
without too much calculation?
The notes would have
the more details.
Can you see -- here's
Lax-Wendroff, Lax-Friedrichs.
So what's the idea
of Lax-Friedrichs?
You remember the total failure,
the complete and absolute
failure when we used a time
difference there and a space
difference there?
You remember that that
gave the time difference
that produced a 1 in G and
this space difference produced
an imaginary part in G, so
we had G as 1 plus something
imaginary and we were outside
the circle automatically.
Friedrichs thought of a
way to get around that.
Instead of using U_(j, n)
here, instead of the backward
difference, he replaced U_(j,
n) by the average of that value
and that value, so that both
sides now involved just two
numbers -- U_(j, n) --
this one and this one.
This one is not used now.
Again, still first order,
you won't be surprised
that this approximation, this
has got first-order error.
But stability, now, is back
with us and easy to check
because now each new value
depends on what old values --
just these two, and
with what coefficients?
So let me just check
stability for Lax-Friedrichs.
So U_(j+1, n), the new value,
is some multiple of this guy,
the one on the left, and
some multiple of this one,
the one on the right.
What are those multiples?
Let's see.
I'm going to move things
over to the right-hand side
of the equation, so I think
there's a half and then I think
there's an r over
-- minus, I guess.
This is the one that comes
in with a minus sign --
it's the one on the left.
And the one on the
right, U_(j+1, n),
there's a half plus r over 2.
Simple idea.
Simple idea and it has one
important advantage over
upwind, one-sided
that we saw last time.
It's not a great method.
It's only first order here.
If I -- and you see when
it's going to be stable?
The coefficients add to 1.
Our coefficients
always add to 1, right?
Because if we have
a constant state,
this next step should
be that same state.
It's not going to change, but
instead of having the typical 1
in the G, I have -- it's
split into a half --
so what is G for this guy?
G for this guy is this number:
1 minus r over 2 times e
to the minus i*k delta x plus
this number times e to the plus
i*k delta x.
You're seeing, now, the pattern.
So I've sort of jumped to
G without plugging in the e
to the i*k*x, taking a step
and then factoring out e
to the i*k*x.
I did it without writing
down the e to the i*k*x.
This is what factors out.
Maybe a 1 plus r
would be more correct.
So stability requires
this complex number,
which I could write
in different ways.
The real part there
would be a cosine.
This would actually be the
cosine plus r times the sine --
plus i*r times the sine.
This is really -- I could
rewrite that as cos k delta x
plus i*r sine k delta x.
I don't know which
way you -- here,
this shows you the real
and imaginary parts.
That makes it nice.
This shows you the
two coefficients.
That makes it nice.
Can you see stability -- so
what is Courant-Friedrichs-Lewy?
The characteristic
discussion, the argument based
on characteristics, says what?
Stability is going
mean that delta t --
stability is going to
happen when r is below 1.
It's just like upwind, except
that r could also be coming --
c could have the opposite sign.
Like Friedrichs
is prepared for c
to be positive or negative,
because it's not purely
upwind or purely downwind.
It's both winds.
You see that if r is anywhere
-- the condition is going to be
that minus 1 is -- r is
between minus 1 and 1 --
see what's nice about
Friedrichs in that case?
This number is positive.
This number is positive, because
the 1 is bigger than the r.
So each step --
and they add to 1.
So each step takes the new value
as a combination of the two
old values and of
course, the magnitude
can't be bigger than 1.
So under this condition, I
have positive coefficients.
That's positive and
that's positive.
They multiply things of absolute
value 1, so they can't --
the sum can't get beyond 1
-- or you might like it here,
that magnitude squared is
cosined squared plus r squared
sine squared, and
if r is below 1,
we're smaller than cosine
squared plus sine squared,
which is 1.
So if I draw the --
just for a moment,
if I draw the G in
the complex plane --
so there's the unit circle.
k equals 0 is always there.
That's at 1, then
these points --
I think probably those points
fall on an ellipse here,
where we go up as high as r, or
magnitude of r, and we go left,
right as far as -- this
is k delta x equal pi --
as far as minus 1.
So it's stable if
this is less than 1.
Nothing hard.
In fact, easy.
Two positive numbers
that add to 1.
Now, I've added a problem
in the problem set.
Not requiring it to be turned
in, but just to mention it here
-- that whenever the
coefficients are all positive,
the accuracy could
only be first order,
so we can't get too far
with positive coefficients.
First-order accuracy
is the best possible,
except in the extreme
case when we're
right on the characteristic.
So if r was exactly 1 -- you
remember that special case when
r is exactly 1 and we're
following exactly the line that
carries the true
information -- r is 1.
That's gone and this is just
-- so if r is 1, then U_(j+1,
n) is U -- is this,
is that number,
and we're just carrying
that information exactly.
I have to say, again,
that the idea of trying
to follow that characteristic
is a totally natural one
and I'm not writing down, here,
a method that tries to do that,
but it wouldn't be a bad
idea in one dimension.
You couldn't do it, really,
well in higher dimensions
where these ideas do
continue to apply.
So that's Lex-Friedrichs.
That's Lex-Friedrichs.
So now, let me turn
to Lax-Wendroff.
These are natural ideas, but
Lax and Wendroff did it first.
They said, if I use these
three values, all three,
then certainly I can
get the accuracy up
one more because I have one
more coefficient to choose.
And to see what they
did, the easiest way
is to write it as
a time difference
on the left to see
how they match.
All they want to do with match
that second term, that delta x
squared term in
the Taylor series.
Because this is going
to give us a d by dt,
this will give us
a d by dx centered,
so we get extra accuracy there,
and the matching that we need
is this term.
Do you recognize that?
What does that term approximate?
Hope I've got it right.
That term approximates
u_xx, right?
So this is -- they've thrown in
a term that approximates u_xx,
and its purpose is to catch
the next order of accuracy,
and hopefully not
lose stability,
hopefully remain stable.
So what Lax-Wendroff are
doing is staying even closer
to this curve.
I guess I have forgotten exactly
what their curve will be.
If I write down G -- Oh, maybe
you could ask MATLAB to do
that.
Write down the G for
this, for Lax-Wendroff --
it's got that extra term --
and plot absolute value of G.
I guess you might plot it along
with the Lax-Friedrichs value.
So what am I guessing?
I'm pretty sure that
the Lax-Wendroff
one will hug the unit
circle more closely,
but it'll stay inside.
So can I just -- Lax-Wendroff
is G closer to 1,
at least for small k,
at least for small k.
That's really where the
accuracy is checked.
How close does these
Taylor series match?
Lax-Wendroff match better
and they stay inside.
That takes a little calculation.
Took me a while yesterday to
rewrite the -- write out the G,
square the real part, square
the imaginary part, add them up,
and this is what I got.
So for Lax-Wendroff,
I got G squared
is 1 minus r squared minus
r to the fourth times 1
minus cosine k delta x squared.
I put in the notes
eventually, much algebra,
but it does the job.
Because if r squared -- so
what's the stability condition?
It's again this same guy,
the same condition --
r squared below 1.
Again, we could be -- we
could have a left-going wave
and a right-going wave.
Now you'll say, what's
the good of that?
Here we just have one
wave, but on Friday, we'll
have a wave going both ways.
So Lax-Friedrichs
and Lax-Wendroff
can both deal with that.
In fact, their stability
conditions are the same
and in fact, you
may be wondering,
why would anybody use
Lax-Friedrichs when
Lax-Wendroff gives
higher accuracy
at no real significant
increase in cost?
So Lax-Wendroff is a favorite.
Don't forget, still,
experiment has
to be done to see what it really
does in practice, because right
now, everything's looking
in Lax-Wendroff's favor
with one exception.
Lax-Friedrichs, which only
used these two coefficients,
had them positive.
This is positive.
This is positive,
where Lax-Wendroff
is going to have a negative.
Let's see.
Where will our negative -- I
think there'll be a negative
coefficient in here somewhere.
Probably one of the
three outside guys.
I know that we couldn't have
three positive coefficients
and get up to
second-order accuracy.
Now, where do we pay
the price for that?
Where do we pay the price
-- I should finish here.
Suppose r squared's
bigger than 1.
If you accept this calculation,
which has a nice result,
but took a while -- if
r squared's below 1,
then what do I know about G?
Suppose r squared's
bigger than 1.
What can we say
from this formula?
Does that hit you right away?
G -- if r squared -- this
is certainly -- absolute G.
I've taken the actual G
and squared its real part,
squared its imaginary part, did
all the algebra I could think
of, and got this answer.
For the magnitude squared -- so
the magnitude squared is never
going to go below 0.
I don't have to think of that.
It's just I want to
be sure it's below 1.
So all I really want
to do is be sure
that I'm subtracting
something positive.
Am I subtracting
something positive?
That's certainly positive.
Is this positive?
r squared'll be bigger
than r to the fourth.
If r squared's less than
1, then r to the fourth
is even smaller.
So this is positive,
this is positive.
I'm subtracting something, so G
is certainly not bigger than 1.
So that formula really
makes it evident
and I guess also
evident that we're
getting some high accuracy.
You see, what's the size
of this when k is small?
When k is small, if I'm taking
the cosine of a small angle --
what am I looking at there?
If this is a small angle theta,
I'm looking at 1 minus cosine
theta -- that's of what order?
Theta squared.
Then that's squared again,
so that I'm up to theta
to the fourth.
That's why I'm getting
off to a good start.
So stability we've got,
two-sided we've got,
experiment -- can I just try to
draw a little graph of what I
think the two methods will
do for our model problem?
Like this model problem
of a wave moving along?
I want to try to draw it
at, let's say, t equal to 1,
for example.
So at t equal 1, the
wave should be here.
I'll draw -- you might say
this is totally unsatisfactory,
and it is, because I'm just
drawing by hand what you can
see.
Maybe you should.
This would be a perfect
experiment and I really could
use, for the notes -- the
notes could use a proper graph.
I think what you
see -- let's see.
At t equal 1, both methods
are going to be 0 way out here
and they'll be 1 way out here.
Why's that?
Because the signal
speed is finite, right?
This way out here, it hasn't
heard about this wave of water.
Way out here, it doesn't know
that it's not a constant.
The question is, and I guess
the thing has moved, so maybe --
can I try roughly?
So the true wall of
water would be that.
I think that what Lax-Wendroff
-- Lax-Friedrichs --
so Lax-Friedrichs, with
positive coefficients,
will show a smooth profile,
but the perfect signal will get
spread out.
The perfect signal
will get spread out.
Why is that?
Let me just draw a
spread out signal.
So apologies to do this by hand.
I think it's probably going
to be pretty centered,
but it's going to be spread out.
So that, I think, would
be Lax-Friedrichs.
That's very rough, right?
But I really -- hearty thanks
for anybody who gives me a code
that does it and graphs it.
But the main point is, we
have a lot of smearing here.
The accuracy is not
going to be terrific.
But there isn't any bumpiness.
The reason there's no bumpiness
is that we're Lax-Freidrichs
with -- has these
positive coefficients,
so that every value always
has to stay between 0 and 1.
The starting values
were between 0 and 1.
At every step, the values
are between 0 and 1,
because we're always
taking a combination
of a positive
multiple of one value
and another positive
multiple of the other value
and the two coefficients
adding to one.
We're taking 30% of one and
70% of another and we never --
we're always in between
the 0 and the 1.
What about Lax-Wendroff?
What are you expecting
for Lax-Wendroff?
Expecting better
accuracy, expecting --
if I were on the ball,
I'd have another color.
Lax-Wendroff will be a much
better profile, sharper
profile, but you know what
the price is going to be?
There'll be some oscillation.
There'll be some oscillations
behind -- I think behind --
oh gosh, I should know.
Forgive me for -- I can fix
these if you'll tell me how,
on the next -- because
I'm not sure that --
I should know whether
they're at both --
or whether the oscillations
happens at both ends.
I doubt it.
No, I doubt it.
I don't think it will.
Why do I not think it well?
Because in Lax-Wendroff,
the three coefficients --
one of them will be negative
and two will be positive.
They'll add to 1, of course.
So the oscillations,
which are coming
from sometimes a negative
coefficient, sometimes
a positive, will
all be on one side.
So only one of those
oscillations [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So this is my picture of --
can I -- of Lax-Wendroff,
with oscillations
behind the wave front.
All right.
If you've done any
computing, you,
when you see these
oscillations, you immediately
think of somebody's
name, which is Gibbs.
Of course, Gibbs -- do you
remember the Gibbs phenomenon
that comes when you're
approximating a square wave,
like there, by pure
Fourier series?
So the Gibbs, the classical
Gibbs phenomenon is,
take the Fourier series
for a square wave -- well,
it's smooth -- and then
truncate that series,
cut that series off at
100 terms or 1,000 terms.
Gibbs noticed -- and
it's always a problem --
that these oscillations
appear right near the front.
So, far away, no
problem, but here we
really see it only on one
side, because we're not
doing Gibbs' Fourier
series experiment.
We're doing Lax-Wendroff
wave equation.
When I say we, I really
hope you'll do it
and a few lines of MATLAB
will be greatly appreciated.
Maybe Mr. Cho can -- you could
email to him, for example,
a code and the plot.
So what does that tell us?
Tells us Lax-Wendroff has
got a lot of potential,
but this oscillation isn't good.
How are you going
to get rid of it?
How do you get rid of bumpiness?
You introduce diffusion.
So diffusion, heat equation
stuff smooth things out.
Wave equations don't
smooth things out.
This wall of water in the wave
equation stayed a sharp wall.
But we'll see very soon in
the heat equation, diffusion,
viscosity, all those
physical things
connect, numerically,
to a smoother solution,
smoother profile.
So that is really a key
idea, is -- and we'll see it,
but it will make the
problem not linear.
If we want to stay
with a linear equation
and increase the accuracy,
we're going to get oscillation.
But if we locate
the oscillation,
introduce some diffusion
in the right place,
we can reduce the oscillation.
So that's where -- this is what
you really have to do if you
want good output from
numerical methods.
Even on this simple
model problem,
you'll have to have this
idea of numerical viscosity.
Artificial viscosity,
numerical diffusion
popped in at the right spot.
So we'll see that.
Maybe the right place to see it
will be for when the equation
itself is already nonlinear.
That's where it has
developed a lot.
So we'll -- when we get to
nonlinear wave equations,
which isn't far off,
that's what we'll see.
So now, I guess I have one
more topic in this lecture.
That is convergence.
How do you show that -- we know,
we sort of know that we need
stability.
So I guess I'm going
to have to come
to the question of convergence.
All right.
And of course, I have to
mention -- more than mention --
the key result in the whole
theory, the connection --
so we have methods that are
first order or second order --
stable or unstable, and then the
key idea is this Lax -- again,
he enters -- Lax equivalency.
So this is a little bit of
pure math, comes into this,
and it gives exactly the
result we would expect.
Stability implies
convergence and convergence
implies stability.
So that's the two
ideas are equivalent,
provided we're talking
about a decent problem,
for a consistent approximation
to well-posed problems.
I've got four words on the
board, four keywords here.
Stability, we kind of
know what that means.
Convergence.
These are the new words and
I'll just -- and actually --
so consistent means that the
method is at least first order
and that the difference equation
approaches the differential
equation at a single step.
Well-posed means that the
differential equation is OK.
So, for example, what would
be a non-well-posed problem?
When we get to
the heat equation,
if you ran the heat
equation backward in time,
that would give us an
equation du/dt as minus u_xx.
That would be not well-posed.
Or, if you tried to solve
Laplace's equation equation --
say, u_tt plus u_xx equals
0 -- from initial values,
that would not be well-posed.
But we're dealing with
well-posed problems.
The wave equation, which has
the right sign< and the heat
equation with the right sign.
So our problems are
going to be well-posed.
You can safely think
we're only talking
about consistent approximations
to well-posed problems.
Here is the main point.
Stability holds if and only
if the convergence holds.
So there's actually two
things to show there.
How does stability
give convergence?
Why does convergence
require stability?
So that instability could
not [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So that's sort of maybe
the fundamental theorem
of numerical analysis.
The fact that stability, a --
we better say what stability is,
and what is convergence.
So let me capture
these in inequalities,
in mathematical terms
rather than just words.
So those are the ideas -- maybe
I'm going to have to write
a little above here, but -- so
what does -- what's our method?
So I need some notation and
then I'll lift the board
and we'll see what
each thing means.
So our method, we're allowing
any difference method
that moves forward in time.
There's time.
Let me use R for the
true operator that
takes the function, follows
the differential equation
to the next time.
So I'm going to say that true
u, which is always a small u,
at delta t is some R,
something R times u of t,
where the approximate guy
is some s times U of t.
So R is the true solution.
So well-posed.
So of course to take --
if this is n delta t,
then we've taken R n times,
so the true solution is R
to the n-th times
the initial value,
and the approximate guy is
S^n times the initial value
and we'll -- we might as well
start out with those the same.
So that's what R and S are.
Now, we got three ideas here.
What does well-posed mean?
Well-posed means that the
true thing is bounded.
That R to the n-th times u is
less than some constant times
u.
These inequalities
are sort of part
of the mathematics of partial
differential equations.
I think you've got to take
them as not -- I mean,
take them as sort of a
reasonable statement that
the -- this is energy, this
u typically will measure
the energy.
And in our wave equation,
C_1, the constant C_1 will be?
1.
The energy doesn't change.
In another problem, we could
allow the possibility of C_1
being a little bigger than
1, but think of C_1 as 1.
Then, stability will be a
bound on S to the n, say, C_2.
And again, in our
example, C_2 has been 1.
This is like -- C_2
is like -- I mean,
S to the n-th on each
exponential is this G
to the n-th, and G is below 1.
So often, C_1 and C_2 will be 1.
Then finally, what is
this ideas of consistency?
And this means --
consistent means that --
so what's consistency?
Consistent is comparing
the differential equation
with the difference equation.
It's comparing R with
S and at a single step,
they should be close.
So at a single step, R
minus S u, that's the --
starting with the same u,
I'm just taking one step
in the differential equation
and comparing it with one step
in the difference equation --
and I would want that to be
C_3, maybe delta
t to the p plus 1.
Was that -- is that --
times size of u, I think.
Order delta t to the p plus 1.
Like delta t squared.
This would be the usual
situation, that --
when it's stable.
So at the moment then, I want
to say, if these are all true,
then I get
convergence because --
what I'm now going to do is
show that stability implies
convergence.
It's what we did for ordinary
differential equations.
This was the local error.
This is the local error that I
called DE, the discreditization
error.
These are saying -- so
this is saying that the --
here's really what happens.
So I want to look at the
error up here after n steps.
So the error after n
steps -- typical term is,
I follow the
differential equation.
That's u.
Then I have this
little error DE,
which I make at that step, the
difference between R and S,
and then I follow the
difference equation
up to the remaining time.
What I want to show is
that I can track the error
and bound it.
I don't know if you
remember the discussion
for ordinary
differential equations,
but it went the same way.
We had -- we looked at the
new error DE that was produced
at each time step k.
When we took k steps of -- when
we got up to this point with
the true solution, we
plugged the true solution
into the difference equation, it
had a little error and whatever
error there was, that got
thrown in with other errors
and propagated up
to any later time n.
Am I bringing back what
we did there, or just --
you can just see that's what
we're going to have here.
Now, how will I express that?
Somehow, I have to estimate
the difference between R
to the n-th and S to the n-th.
That's really my problem.
Actually, it's a nice problem.
Suppose I have control
of powers of R and S,
and I know that R minus
S is small somehow.
How do I show that R to the n-th
minus S to the n-th is small?
That's my job.
This is the error when I apply
it to a starting value u.
This is the difference
between little u and big U.
So how do I -- what I want to
do is split it out into this
situation where I just
have one R minus S.
I think this'll work.
So suppose I have -- I think
I could start with R to the n
minus 1 times R minus S, and
then an R to the n minus 2
times an R minus S times an
S. Maybe I don't -- sorry,
this guy is going to carry
and I'd rather do -- sorry.
Got to do it right, because
I want the R's to come first.
I want maybe R minus S times
S to the n minus 1 and then --
sorry.
I want R's on the right.
Good.
Finally got it.
So that gives me the R of the
n-th, but I've subtracted off,
so I need an S R minus S R
to the n minus 2 and so on.
Sorry for this bit of algebra in
the middle of practical things,
but do you see that this is
the case where I followed
the differential equation
up and at the last step
I made an error?
This is the case where I
followed the differential
equation almost to the
top, I made an error
and then I had one more step
to go with the difference.
The S is doing this
part, so a typical term
will be a power of S, S
to some power, R minus S,
R to some power.
I'm breaking the
error at n steps
into n different terms, each
from the error at one step.
This is the error
at the last step,
this is the error at the
next-to-last step, and so on.
We've got it.
Because I just
estimate every term,
every term has a power of
R, which gives me a C_1;
a power of S, which
gives me a C_2;
and the discreditization error,
the one-step actual error,
R minus S, which gives me
a C_3; and this delta t
to the p plus 1.
You see that I'm just
piling up n of these,
so I'm getting n of those,
delta t to the p plus 1,
so the final result will be,
I'll have n of these delta t
to the p plus 1's and that
will be T -- n delta t --
delta t to the p.
So that'll be the error.
Since I went to all
the trouble of defining
a C_1, C_2, and C_3,
those three numbers.
So the error -- there'll be
a C_1 times C_2 times C_3
constant there, in the bound.
Have a look at
the notes for that
and let me just conclude
with Lax's insight
on the other part.
The fact that convergence
requires stability.
So you see, what I've shown
is that if we're stable,
if I bound these, bound
these, bound these,
then I have a
bound on the error.
That's convergence.
The other way is,
if it's unstable,
how do you know it
couldn't converge?
How do we know that
convergence requires stability?
It's a little
delicate, so I just --
this is the last 30
seconds of the lecture,
just to mention this point,
because it's easy to miss a key
point here.
We've tracked a different -- now
I'm supposing that the method
is unstable and I want to
show that it will fail, right?
That's my job now.
That's Lax's -- other
half of Lax's theorem:
If it's unstable,
the method will fail.
There'll be some initial
value for which it blows up.
Now you might say, that initial
value is just e to the i*k*x.
But, we didn't
follow this point,
but if I take an e to the i*k*x
where G is bigger than 1 --
of course, that is
getting amplified a bit,
but for that particular
e to the i*k*x,
when delta t decreases --
so if I have a -- you see,
this is a k delta x.
What I'm trying to say
is that for a fixed k,
even an unstable
method can work.
For a fixed frequency k,
as delta t and delta x gets
smaller -- these guys, whether
they're outside or inside,
will be coming down toward
1 and if you're patient,
you could see it
actually worked.
So it's -- somehow, the initial
function that doesn't work,
that blows up, is a
combination of frequencies.
A single frequency, actually,
you move down here and it's not
catastrophic in the end, but
a combination of frequencies,
so that as one
frequency moves down,
another one is moving
into this position,
another one into this -- there
is a typical initial function
and it is disaster.
So that's what Lax had to catch.
The notes will use the single
word, uniform boundedness.
Anyway, this is one
point where pure math --
a kind of neat result in pure
math says that if stability
fails, then there is some single
starting value on which it will
fail.
That starting value won't
be a pure e to the i*k*x,
because it, as we said, actually
in the end gets to be OK,
but there will be a combination
of frequencies that'll fail
and so convergence will fail.
So that's the key theorem.
I probably won't use
the word theorem again,
but this is one time
when it's justified
and when a little sort of
abstract functional analysis
gives the conclusion that
convergence requires stability.
So you'll see that in
the notes and next time,
we move on to the true wave
equation, second order.
Thanks.